Anyone who has ever been married or been in a long-term relationship has probably heard the well-worn adage that relationships take work. And it's true that for almost every couple, some issues will crop up around money, fidelity, health, kids, or even just coping with the stress of everyday life together. When those issues arise and partners cannot resolve them, couple therapists can often help partners work through them together to build a stronger, more fulfilling relationship. So today, we're going to talk to a couple psychologist about how couple therapy works. What types of issues can therapists help partners address? How do you know if you and your significant other might benefit from couple therapy? What if you want to go to couple therapy and your partner doesn't? How do you know when it's time to end a relationship rather than continue to work on it?
任何结过婚或处于长期关系中的人都可能听过那句老生常谈的话：经营关系需要付出努力。对于几乎每一对伴侣来说，在金钱、忠诚、健康、子女，甚至仅仅是共同应对日常生活压力等方面，确实都会出现一些问题。当这些问题出现而伴侣无法解决时，伴侣治疗师通常可以帮助他们共同克服困难，建立更稳固、更令人满意的关系。因此，今天我们将与一位伴侣心理学家探讨伴侣治疗是如何运作的。治疗师可以帮助伴侣解决哪些类型的问题？你如何知道你和你的另一半是否能从伴侣治疗中受益？如果你想进行伴侣治疗，但你的伴侣不想去怎么办？你如何知道什么时候该结束一段关系，而不是继续努力经营它？
And what research-based advice can help us all build stronger, happier, healthier relationships? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Anthony Chambers. Dr. Chambers is a board-certified couple and family psychologist, a professor of clinical psychology at Northwestern University, and the chief academic officer of the Northwestern Family Institute. He is a scientist practitioner who conducts research on couple and family therapy and uses research to inform his work with patients.
还有哪些基于研究的建议可以帮助我们所有人建立更稳固、更幸福、更健康的关系？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是安东尼·钱伯斯博士。钱伯斯博士是一位获得委员会认证的伴侣与家庭心理学家，西北大学临床心理学教授，也是西北家庭研究所的首席学术官。他是一位科学家兼从业者，致力于伴侣和家庭治疗的研究，并利用研究成果指导他的临床工作。
He is the author of many book chapters and journal articles summarizing the science behind assessing and treating common couple issues such as communication, trust, intimacy, parenting, and conflict resolution. He has also taught an undergraduate course at Northwestern University called Building Loving and Lasting Relationships, Marriage, Wants. 101. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Chambers. Thank you so much. Thank you for the invitation, and I'm thrilled to be able to be here, to be able to talk about one of my favorite topics here, which is a couple of relationships. All right. Well, let's get going. I want to start by asking a basic question. How is couple therapy different from, and similar to individual therapy? Where do the goals and treatment diverge and overlap? The probably the single biggest difference between a couple of
他撰写了许多书籍章节和期刊文章，总结了评估和治疗常见伴侣问题（如沟通、信任、亲密关系、育儿和冲突解决）背后的科学。他还在西北大学教授一门名为“建立充满爱与持久的关系：婚姻101”的本科课程。感谢您今天加入我的节目，钱伯斯博士。非常感谢。谢谢您的邀请，我很高兴能来到这里，谈论我最喜欢的话题之一，那就是伴侣关系。好的，让我们开始吧。我想先问一个基本问题。伴侣治疗与个人治疗有何不同，又有哪些相似之处？它们的目标和治疗方式在哪些方面存在分歧和重叠？伴侣治疗与个人治疗之间最大的区别其实在于谁是真正的客户。
couple therapy and individual therapy is actually who the actual client is. When you are in couple therapy, the client is the relationship. You're focused on being able to help the relationship, trying to understand what are the constraints and things that get in the way of being able to have a healthy relationship. And that really is the focus. A couple therapy is not about coming into the courtroom and to be able to see, okay, who's right and who's wrong. This is a about being able to focus on how to be able to have the kind of relationship that you're looking for. And so it's really important that people are able to make that kind of distinction when they're thinking about couple therapy versus individual therapy. How do you know when it's time
当你进行伴侣治疗时，客户是“这段关系”。你的重点是帮助这段关系，试图理解是什么限制和阻碍了你们建立健康的关系。这才是重点。伴侣治疗不是为了来到法庭，看看谁对谁错。这是为了专注于如何建立你所期待的那种关系。因此，当人们考虑伴侣治疗与个人治疗时，能够做出这种区分非常重要。你如何知道什么时候该寻求伴侣治疗？换句话说，一个人如何判断他们和伴侣是否能从伴侣治疗中受益，而不是仅仅试图自己解决关系问题？嗯，首先，我认为几乎每个人都能从某种形式的伴侣治疗中受益。你知道，我们都是社会性动物。我们天生就非常倾向于建立关系。然而，我们几乎没有接受过如何建立成功关系的培训。出于某种原因，我们倾向于认为，仅仅因为我们是成年人，就应该能够拥有一段健康的关系。但事实并非如此。因此，我认为伴侣治疗实际上对几乎每个人都有帮助，因为它可以让人学习
to seek couple therapy? In other words, how can a person tell when they and their partner could benefit from couple therapy rather than just trying to work through relationship problems on their own? Well, first of all, I think almost everyone can benefit from some type of couple therapy. You know, we are all social beings. We're all actually very much wired towards relationships. However, we receive very little training on how to be able to have a successful relationship. For some reason, we tend to think that, you know, we should just be able to have a healthy relationship by the functioned effect that we're an adult. But that's not really the case. And so I think couple therapy actually can be helpful for literally just about everyone in terms of being able to learn
（注：此段落与上一段落内容有重叠，根据原文逻辑，此处应为：）学习如何建立健康关系的技能和工具。话虽如此，我确实认为，如果一对伴侣反复争吵，却无法在解决这些关系问题上取得任何进展，那么这应该是一个真正的信号，表明我们需要寻求额外的帮助，因为很明显，我们一直在原地打转，没有取得我们想要的进展。所以这就像一件反复发生的事情。你们有同样的争吵或同类型的争吵，而且总是陷入僵局。所以确实是时候找人来帮助你们找出如何以不同的方式行事了。绝对是这样。绝对是。我还想指出我认为这方面另一个非常重要的因素，
the skills and the tools for how to be able to have a healthy relationship. Now, that being said, I do think that it's important that if a couple is having repeated arguments and they are not able to get any kind of headway and how to be able to solve those relationship problems, then that should be a real sign that, okay, we definitely need to get some additional help because clearly we're going around in circles and we're not making the kind of headway that we want to be able to make. So it's like a recurring thing. You have the same argument or type of argument and you always end up at an impasse. So it's really time for somebody to come help you figure out how to behave differently. Absolutely. Absolutely. And I should also point out another, I think, really important aspect to this,
那就是你寻求帮助的对象也很重要，这意味着几乎所有的治疗师都受过治疗个人的培训，但其中只有相对较少比例的治疗师受过良好的伴侣治疗培训。我们知道，对于伴侣来说，要获得良好的伴侣治疗体验，确保他们从受过良好伴侣治疗培训的人那里获得帮助，并且该治疗师将伴侣治疗作为其临床实践的主要部分，这是一个非常重要的因素。所以我确实认为人们在寻找能够帮助他们解决关系中挣扎的人时，进行尽职调查非常重要。那么，为了深入探讨这个想法，是否有某些形式的治疗比其他形式更有效？你找到了一个伴侣治疗师，但你怎么知道那个人是否适合你？我实际上会说，不同类型的治疗在共同点上比在差异上更多。有一个完整的文献领域叫做“共同因素”。共同因素基本上意味着，任何好的伴侣治疗中都包含某些特定的要素。我们已经开始在文献中大量讨论，许多研究人员和学者已经开始致力于
which is it also matters who you are going to seek help from, meaning that almost all therapists, are actually trained in treating individuals, but a relatively fewer proportion of those therapists are actually well trained in being able to work with couples. And we know that that's just a really important factor for a couple to be able to have a good experience in couple therapy to be able to make sure that they are receiving trained and that they're receiving help from someone who has been well trained in working with couples, and someone who has couples as a primary part of their purpose. clinical practice. So I do think it's important that people do their due diligence in being
综合所有这些不同的部分。因此，就各种伴侣治疗方法而言，相似之处多于差异。话虽如此，我认为非常重要的一点是，再次强调，确保伴侣治疗师接受过伴侣治疗的督导培训。有时你可以通过他们是否获得委员会认证来判断，例如我本人，如果你获得了伴侣治疗的委员会认证，那就意味着根据定义，你已经接受了大量的督导培训。有些人可能拥有婚姻和家庭治疗的学位。很有可能他们也接受过伴侣治疗的督导培训。所以我认为这是一个非常重要的部分。我还想说，再次强调，能够询问治疗师，你的病例中有多少比例是伴侣？在我的诊所里，我想大概90%的病例是伴侣。我大约10%的时间用于个人治疗。所以我认为，能够找到一个至少50%的病例是伴侣的治疗师，意味着伴侣治疗确实是他们的专业领域之一。最后，你知道，从朋友那里获得良好推荐的传统方式。如果你有一个朋友曾经进行过伴侣治疗，并且体验良好，那么我认为这也是另一个
able to find someone who can help them with their struggles that they're having in their relationship. So to go a little deeper on that idea, are there particular forms of therapy that are more effective than others? You find somebody who's a couple therapists, but how do you know that that person is going to be right for you? I would actually say there are more things in common than there are different in terms of the different types of. therapy. There's a whole literature out there called common factors. And common factors basically means that there are certain ingredients that really are part of any good couple therapy. And we've been starting to take a lot in the literature, a lot of researchers and scholars have started to work on
指标，也许你可以确信这也是一个有望为你提供良好体验的人。那么，如果你想进行伴侣治疗，但你的伴侣不想去，会发生什么？伴侣中的一方可以通过独自进行治疗来修复或改善关系吗？我会说，首先，治疗关系问题的最好方法是让这段关系“在房间里”。你知道，一个巴掌拍不响。所以，即使治疗师是善意的，如果他们只是在交谈并听取一个人的观点，你就无法获得可能对关系和问题有完全不同看法的伴侣的视角。因此，我总是试图鼓励伴侣的一件事是，例如，如果有人打电话给我，说：“嘿，我想来做治疗，专注于我的关系，但我知道我的伴侣不太愿意来。”我会当场进行对话，试图看看我们是否能鼓励伴侣过来，因为我们从文献中知道，如果只有一个人来寻求关系帮助，关系破裂或离婚的几率更高。因为治疗师只听取了一个人的意见。在某个时刻，无论治疗师意图多么良好，他们都会说：“哦，那么是什么让你留在这段关系中呢？”
being able to synthesize all of those different pieces. So there's more similarities than there are differences in terms of the various couple therapy approaches. That being said, I I think what's really important is that, again, making sure that the couple therapists has received supervised training in working with couples. And you can be able to figure that out sometimes by if they are board certified, for instance, such as myself, if you're board certified in couple therapy, then that means by definition you've received a lot of supervised training. someone might have a degree in marriage and family therapy. Good chance that they've received supervised training and working with couples. So I think that's a really important piece. I would also say, again, being able to ask the therapist, what percentage of your caseload are
“你为什么还留在这里？”之类的话。结果你发现，这段关系反而增加了关系无法维持的风险。所以我总是试图鼓励人们说：“嘿，你知道吗，让我们看看能不能让你伴侣也来。”有一个策略，我这样做，你知道，我在与伴侣工作时有一种方法，我会进行四次评估。但是，你知道，你可以做的一般性事情是说：“嘿，让我们看看你的伴侣是否愿意至少来几次，也许三四次来尝试一下，你不必签下终身合同。这只是为了看看你是否认为这合适。”我会说十有八九，
couples? In my practice, I would say probably 90% of my practice are couples. I do about 10% with individuals. And so I think being able to see someone where at least 50% of their caseload are working with couples, that means that they, are really couples therapy is one of their areas of expertise. And then finally, you know, the old school way of being able to get a good referral from a friend. If you had a friend who was in couples therapy and they had a good experience, then I think that's also another
当一个对来治疗持矛盾态度的人，在来了几次之后意识到：“哦，这其实并不坏。它确实有帮助。”他们中90%的人通常会留下来。所以我认为这对伴侣来说是一个非常重要的关注点。当一对伴侣来找你进行治疗时，你从哪里开始？你是分开谈，一起谈，还是两者兼有？你使用什么流程来找出帮助他们的最佳方法？当然。正如我刚才提到的，我进行所谓的四次评估。这意味着我首先会和伴侣一起见面，谈论他们的关系。我想听听他们每个人对关系优势以及显然是关系担忧的看法。然后，我为他们每个人安排一次个人会谈，这样我就可以更多地了解他们的个人历史、原生家庭等。然后我们将作为一个小组再次聚在一起。在第四次会谈中，我给他们反馈，关于我认为发生了什么，
indicator perhaps that you can be assured that this is someone also who can hopefully provide good training for a good experience for you. Now, what happens if you want to go to couple therapy and your partner doesn't? Can one half a couple do anything to fix a relationship or improve a relationship by going to therapy alone? I would say that first, the best way to treat a relationship problem is by having the relationship in the room. It is, you know, it takes two to tango. And so, you know, a therapist, even though they're well meaning and intentioned, if they're only talking and hearing the perspective of one person, you're not doing. getting the perspective of the partner who may have a very different perspective about the relationship
并制定一个良好的前进计划。这就是我采取的方法。我知道还有许多其他伴侣治疗师也采用非常相似的流程，试图系统地理解关系和个人。回到我们刚才讨论的观点，当你只是报名参加四次会谈时，它感觉并没有那么令人生畏。所以如果有人对来治疗持矛盾态度，他们更有可能说：“好吧，我报名参加几次会谈，看看这到底是怎么运作的。”如果他们觉得我有帮助，那么我们就会继续。同样，超过90%的情况下，那个持矛盾态度的人在进来并意识到这可能不是他们最初害怕的那样之后，确实会留下来。所以，如果一对伴侣承诺进行治疗，并真的想和你或像你这样的人一起努力，你对他们应该预期进行多久的治疗有什么了解吗？我会说这是评估过程的一部分，因为它确实因人而异。你知道，如果一对伴侣是婚前来的，他们在约会，试图弄清楚他们的关系。
and the problems. And so one of the things I am always trying to encourage couples, if someone calls me on the phone, for instance, and they're saying, hey, I want to come in for therapy to focus on my relationship, but I know my partner is not really willing to come in. I will have a conversation right then and there to try to see if we can't encourage the partner to be able to come in, because we do know from the literature, there is a higher rate of the relationship dissolving or divorce if one individual is coming in to treat, to be able to get help for their relationship. Because that therapist is only hearing from one person. And at some point, that therapist, no matter how well intended, they're say, oh, so what keeps you in this relationship?
他们没有很长的关系历史。这与我看到的结婚30年、有三个孩子、彼此有很多历史的伴侣是非常不同的。这确实取决于提出的问题、他们关系的阶段。所以我会在全面范围内说的是，你知道，从我的角度来看，治疗是为了让我能够“失业”，意思是我想尽快给他们所需的工具和技能，这样他们就可以继续应用到生活中并向前迈进。现在，有时我们确实有，我有时也把自己看作家庭医生，家庭医学医生，我会因为他们一生中不同阶段的压力源而多次见到一对伴侣。因为有时会有一些可预测的压力源，也有一些不可预测的压力源会出现。他们可能需要回来谈论具体的事情。
Why are you still in this and things along those lines? And next thing you know, the relationship has increased the risk for the relationship, not. working. So I always try to encourage people to say, hey, you know what, let's see if we can't get your partner in. One strategy, and I do this, you know, I have an approach when I work with couples where I do a four session evaluation. But, you know, one thing in general that you could do is say, hey, let's see if your partner is willing to come in just for at least a handful of sessions, maybe three or four sessions to try it out, that you don't have to sign up for life. This is just to be able to see whether or not, you know, you think it's a good fit. And I would say nine times out of ten,
因此，我们将建立一种通常是长期的关系，即使任何一个特定的阶段可能只是短期的。那么，促使人们寻求伴侣治疗帮助的最常见问题是什么？沟通，你知道，不出所料，这是最大的一个。这可能是很多伴侣进来时会说的：“是的，我们在沟通上有困难。”他们也会因为诸如向父母身份过渡等问题而来。向父母身份过渡是伴侣将面临的第一大可预测压力源。大多数离婚实际上发生在向父母身份过渡期间。所以这是一个压力很大的时期。所以这是一个相当可预测的时间段，伴侣们意识到：“天哪，这些问题现在太让人不知所措了”，
when a person who is ambivalent about coming in, and then they come in and they realize after a few sessions, oh, this actually isn't so bad. It actually can be helpful. 90% of them usually stay. And so I think that's a really important piece for couples out there to be able to pay attention to. When a couple comes to you for therapy, where do you start? Do you talk to them separately, together, both? What's the process that you use to figure out how best to help them? Sure. So as I was just referring to, I do something was called a four-session evaluation. And so what that means is I'm going to meet with the couple first together to be able to talk about their relationship. I want to hear each of their perspectives about the relationship strengths as well as obviously their relationship concerns. And then I schedule an individual session with each of them so I can be able to understand more about their individual histories, their families of origin, things along those lines. and then we will come back together as a group. And in that fourth session, I give them my feedback about what I think is going on
然后他们就会进来。不忠是伴侣寻求治疗的第一大原因。有趣的是，这不是他们离婚的第一大原因，但却是伴侣寻求治疗的第一大原因。因此，对于任何治疗师来说，显然知道如何治疗不忠变得很重要，因为它是一个如此常见的呈现问题。但它是可以治疗的，对吧？我的意思是，肯定有伴侣可以度过难关。绝对是。这正是为什么它不是伴侣离婚的第一大原因，因为它实际上是相当可治疗的。而且实际上，我不仅会说它是可治疗的，它还有转化的潜力，突然之间，当你面临
and developing a good plan for moving forward. And so that's the approach that I take. And I know that there are a lot of other couples therapists who also engage in a very similar process of trying to be able to be systematic about understanding the relationship and the individual. And to go back to the point we were just discussing earlier, when you're just signing up for four sessions, it doesn't feel quite as intimidating. So if someone is ambivalent about coming in, they're more likely to say, okay, I'm signing up for a handful of sessions to see how this sort of
这场危机时，你开始，当双方都愿意进来并说，他们对发生的事情感到痛苦，并且他们愿意付出努力说：“我们需要改变我们的关系，因为显然我们所做的一切导致了我们现在的困难点。”我在治疗期间经历过的一些最有力的会谈实际上是在有不忠行为时与伴侣一起工作。所以这绝对是可以治疗的。研究也证实了这一点，它实际上具有非常好的疗效。那么换个角度，我想我们可能都会同意治疗并不总能挽救一段关系。作为一名治疗师，你如何知道什么时候该结束一段关系，而不是让
works. And if they feel like I can be helpful, then we will continue. And again, over 90% of the time, the person that was ambivalent does actually stay once they sort of come in and they realize that this is perhaps not what they initially were fearful of. So if a couple commits to therapy and really wants to do the work with you or somebody like you, do you have any sense of about how long they should expect to be in therapy? I would say that that's part of the assessment process because it really is, it varies quite a bit. You know, if a couple is coming in who's premarital, they're dating and they're trying to figure out their relationship.
伴侣继续努力经营它？你如何让伴侣明白是时候分手了？还是说那不是你的工作？作为治疗师，我们通常尽量不这样做，这总是伴侣的决定，无论他们是想留在一段关系中还是分手。我认为从道德上讲，治疗师说“你应该分手”或“你应该在一起”是非常棘手的领域。话虽如此，我认为好的伴侣治疗师会指出任何重复的模式，会指出事情何时是，你知道，这些限制看起来确实非常深刻等等。有时，伴侣治疗的一个好结果实际上是进行一次健康的“分手”。这实际上是某些伴侣可以
They don't have a long relationship history. That's going to be very different than a couple that I see that's been married for 30 years with three kids and they have a lot of history with each other. It really depends on the presenting problem, the stage of their relationship. And so what I will say across the board, though, is that, you know, therapy is about, from my perspective, I want to be able to get out of business with this couple, meaning I want to give them the tools and skills that they need as quickly as possible so they can be able to go on and to apply them to their lives and be able to move forward. Now, sometimes we do have, I sometimes also see myself as a family doc, family medicine doc, where I'm going to see a couple for different episodes over the course of their life. Because sometimes there are certain stressors that are predictable, some that are unpredictable that will come up. And they may need to return to be able to talk about a specific thing.
非常重要和有帮助的事情，当意识到我们只是不合适，我们有太多的挑战时，我喜欢能够朝着那个方向努力。所以我们会谈论如何进行一次健康的分手。但话虽如此，我认为有一些可预测的警告信号，对吧？所以，如果有一种持续的绝望感，无论你做什么，你只是对这段关系感到绝望，那应该是一个警告信号。任何形式的药物滥用，那将是一个潜在的风险因素。它可以被治疗，但当你谈论药物使用问题时，这是一个非常棘手的领域。所以你真的必须对此保持警惕。当然，一个大问题是家庭暴力。家庭暴力，
And so we're going to develop a relationship that oftentimes is going to be long term, even though any one particular episode may only be for a shortened, of time. So what are the most common issues that drive people to seek a couple therapists help? So communication, you know, not surprisingly, the big one. That's probably what a lot of couples will come in and say, yeah, we're having a hard time communicating. They will also come in for issues such as the transition to parenthood. The transition to parenthood is the number one predictable stressor that a couple will face. Most divorces actually happen. the transition to parenthood. So it's a very stressful time. So that's a fairly predictable time period where couples are realizing, oh my gosh, these problems are just now overwhelming and
我指的是情感虐待、身体虐待、性虐待。在一段关系中发生任何形式的这些问题都是不健康的。如果你发现自己处于一种发生这种动态的关系中，而你在一起的伴侣不愿意参与或改变这一点，那在这一点上应该是一个巨大的警告信号，表明这段关系不再是一个健康的地方。所以我认为这些是伴侣需要注意的一些真正的大警告信号。你对那些可能目前觉得不需要伴侣治疗，但想学习如何加强关系的听众有什么建议？
they will come in. Infidelity is the number one reason why couples come in for therapy. Interesting, it's not the number one reason why they get divorced, but it's the number one reason why couples come in for therapy. And so it becomes important for any therapist that's going to obviously know how to be able to treat infidelity because it's such a common presenting problem. But it is treatable, right? I mean, there are definitely couples who can get through it. Absolutely. That's exactly, which is why it's not the number one reason why couples get divorced, because it actually is quite treatable. And actually, not only I would say is it treatable, it has the potential to be transformational, that all of a sudden that when you're faced with
所以外面总是有很多很棒的研讨会，很多伴侣研讨会，我总是建议伴侣如果他们只是想加强关系，可以去寻找不同的研讨会或周末度假，他们可以在那里学习如何建立健康的关系。我认为这对一些伴侣来说真的会大有帮助。有很多关于如何建立健康关系的很棒的自助书籍。话虽如此，重要的是双方都愿意参与其中，因为就像我说的，一个巴掌拍不响。没有一个人能够完全改变或修复一段关系。
this crisis, you're starting to now, when both members are, willing to come in and to say, and they are distraught by what's happened, and they are willing to do the work to say, we need to transform our relationship, because clearly what we were doing has led us to this difficult point. Some of the most powerful sessions in periods of therapy that I've had is actually working with couples when there has been infidelity. So it is absolutely something that is treatable. And the research bears that out that it actually has really good efficacy. So changing gears a little bit, I think we would probably agree that therapy can't always save a relationship. How do you as a therapist know when it's time for a relationship to end rather than for the
这需要，你知道，需要两个人才能建立一段健康的关系。只需要一个人就可以结束它，但需要两个人才能进步、茁壮成长并治愈。所以我认为，这对于加强任何类型的关系来说都是一个非常重要的部分。在疫情期间，很多治疗和各种医疗保健都变成了虚拟的。它上线了。现在有很多伴侣治疗也是远程进行的吗？它同样有效吗？我的意思是，作为一名治疗师，如果你看不到伴侣在Zoom上是如何互动的，你知道，
couple to continue to work on it? And how do you get the couple to see that it's time to split? Or is that not your job? So as therapist in general, we try not to, it's always the couple. It's always the couple. couple's decision to whether or not they want to stay in a relationship or break up. I think ethically becomes very dicey terrain for a therapist to say, oh, you should break up or you should stay together. That being said, I think a good couple therapists will point out any repeated patterns, will point out when things are, you know, these constraints that do seem quite profound or what have you. And sometimes a good outcome, actually, for a couple therapy is to have a healthy breakup. That actually is something that for some couples can actually be
他们是坐在沙发两端，他们会伸手触碰对方吗？他们会看对方吗？如果你看不到这些，作为治疗师，你能有多有效？首先，研究表明伴侣治疗在Zoom上是有效的。显然，由于疫情，进行了更多的研究，显然在理解面对面治疗与远程治疗的有效性和细微差别方面有了真正的增长。但针对伴侣的远程治疗确实有效。
quite important and helpful that when it gets realized we're just not a good fit and we have too many challenges and things here I like to be able to move towards. So we'll talk about how to be able to have a healthy breakup. But that being said, I think there are some predictable warning signs, right? So if there is a consistent sense of hopelessness, that just no matter what you're just feeling hopeless about the relationship, that should be a warning sign. Any kind of substance abuse, that's going to be a potential risk factor for this. It can be treated, but it's a very dicey terrain when you're talking about substance use issues. And so you really have to be mindful about that. A big one, of course, is domestic violence. And domestic violence,
而且它还在继续。所以在我目前的病例中，我的诊所仍然是100%远程的。我还没有遇到过一个伴侣要求过来。便利因素是显著的，你只是有更多的灵活性。所以伴侣们真的，你知道，很享受伴侣治疗。老实说，我不确定，因为我的诊所可能100%是面对面的。也许我有一两个远程客户，但大部分都是面对面的。所以我对这种变化将如何运作持怀疑态度。我必须告诉你，它真的超出了我对能够做到这一点的预期。现在，有些事情，你知道，治疗师受过如何能够，
I'm talking about emotional abuse, physical abuse, sexual abuse. There is just no, there it is not healthy to have any form of any of those issues happening in a relationship. If you're finding yourself in a relationship where there is that sort of dynamic happening and the partner that you're with is not willing to engage or to change that, that really should be a huge warning sign at that point that this relationship is no longer a healthy place. So there's some real, I think those are some of the real big warning signs that a couple needs to be mindful of. What advice do you have for listeners who maybe they don't feel the need for couple therapy at this point, but they want to learn how to strengthen their relationship?
关于如何有效进行远程治疗的培训更多了。所以对于伴侣，你知道，例如，我经常鼓励他们待在同一个房间里，而不是分屏。这样我就可以看到那些，是的，是的，那些动态。我认为他们待在同一个屏幕上，能够看到他们有什么样的眼神交流等，这对他们实际上是有帮助的。我会让他们调整摄像头。如果我看不清他们的脸，或者类似的事情，我想确保我能看到他们的全脸以及尽可能多的身体，这样我就可以观察肢体语言，因为治疗师总是扫描以观察事情是如何被接收的。所以有些事情是你需要有意识地去做的，以确保
So there's always a lot of great workshops that are out there, a lot of couple workshops, and I would always recommend that couples if they're interested in just strengthening you to go and look for different workshops or weekend getaways that they can be able to, or they can learn about how to have a healthy relationship. I think that really will go a long ways for some couples. There's a lot of great self-help books on how to be able to have a healthy relationship. That being said, it's important that both members are willing to engage in it because just like I said, it takes two to tango. No one person can be able to, you know, fully change or fix a relationship.
远程治疗是有效的。但在考虑到这些注意事项的情况下，它实际上运作得相当好。你几年前写过一篇学术文章，题为《“黑人的命也是命”运动：给伴侣和家庭治疗师的行动呼吁》。你的研究兴趣之一是针对非裔美国伴侣的伴侣治疗。你能谈谈这一点，以及为什么治疗师在与来自不同背景的伴侣工作时考虑这些因素很重要吗？对于非裔美国伴侣，我们的关系面临很多挑战。所以非裔美国人的结婚率最低。
It takes, you know, it takes two to have a healthy relationship. It only takes one to end it, but it takes two to be able to progress and thrive and be able to heal. And so it becomes, I think, a real important piece for being able to strengthen any kind of relationship. During the pandemic, a lot of therapy and health care of all kinds has become virtual. It's gone online. Is a lot of couple therapy being done remotely as well these days? And is it equally effective? I mean, as a therapist, if you can't see how a couple is interacting on Zoom, you know,
他们的离婚率最高。所以如果你想一想，我们确实在很多关系中挣扎。70%的非裔美国儿童是婚外生的。所以当你开始坐下来思考这些统计数据和动态时，这是一个非常强大的问题和机会，我会说，看看我们是否能加强这些关系。因此，我们正在谈论的这些针对非裔美国伴侣的因素对于建立健康的关系变得非常关键。
are they sitting at opposite ends of the couch, do they reach out and touch each other? Do they ever look at one another? If you can't see that, how effective can you be as a therapist? First of all, the research shows that a couple therapy is effective over Zoom. And so obviously there's a lot more research being done because of the pandemic that has been obviously a real increase in being able to understand the effectiveness and the nuances of in-person therapy versus teletherapy. But teletherapy for couples really does work.
如果你来自一个没有看到健康关系的背景，你可能会得到这种代际模式，对吧？我们知道，在单亲家庭中长大的孩子，他们自己离婚且没有那种关系的几率高出50%。所以你会得到这种代际发生的模式。因此，有这样一个机会来提供关于如何建立健康关系的信息。什么构成了健康的关系？我们需要做些什么？因为有时人们只是不知道。这几乎类似于，你知道，如果你要创业，你可能会做一些研究来弄清楚如何确保
And it's still happening. So in my caseload right now, my practice is still 100% remote. I have not had a single couple yet even request to be able to come in. The convenience factor is significant where being able, you just have more flexibility. And so couples are really, you know, enjoying the couple therapy. And I was not sure, to be honest, because my practice was 100% in person probably. Maybe I had one or two remote clients, but for the most part, it was all in person. And so I was skeptical about how that change was going to work. And I got to tell you, it's really surpassed my expectations for being able to do that. Now, there are some things that, you know, therapists are trained in how to be able to,
这个生意会成功。我们需要为我们的关系做非常类似的事情。因为有时由于我们自己过去的创伤或发生的事情，或者我们没有看到的东西，有时看起来直观的事情实际上是反直觉的，实际上你需要做不同的事情才能在关系中取得成功，而不是你有时可能认为的那样。所以对于像非裔美国伴侣这样没有那种建立健康关系的历史和背景的伴侣来说，进来寻求帮助变得非常重要，因为情况是可以好转的。伴侣治疗对于合法结婚的人和那些只是住在一起的人（即使很多年）是否不同？伴侣治疗师对待同性伴侣和异性伴侣的方式有何不同吗？相似之处远多于差异，但差异是我们必须注意的。所以伴侣治疗师绝对会看同性伴侣、非二元性别伴侣，所以这绝对是伴侣治疗师工作的一部分。我会说，就像我之前提到的，找到
there's been a lot more trainings on how to do teletherapy effectively. And so with couples, you know, for instance, I'm oftentimes encouraging them to be in the room with each other versus a split screen. So I can be able to see those sorts of, yep, yep, those sorts of dynamics. I think that actually is helpful for them to be in the same screen to be able to see what kind of eye contact and things that they're having. I will have them adjust their camera. If I can't see enough of their face, for instance, or something along those lines, I want to make sure that I can see their full face and as much of their body as possible so I can be able to look for body languages because therapists are always scanning to be able to look for how things are being received. So there are things like that that you are needing to be intentional about in terms of making sure that. that the teletherapy is effective.
一个好的伴侣治疗师的重要性。找到一个也熟悉同性伴侣细微差别的人也会有帮助，因为有一些重要的差异和需要注意的事情。但这绝对是伴侣治疗师会处理和治疗的事情。合法结婚的人和只是住在一起的人之间有区别吗？你对待他们的方式一样吗？他们有同样的问题，还是他们的问题不同？所以他们在拥有长期关系方面大多是相似的，但当你同居而不结婚时，确实有一些不同，最大的区别是，有时你没有那种关于承诺的保护，关于我试图提出的事情，
But with those caveats in mind, actually, it does work quite well. You wrote an academic article a couple of years ago called the Black Lives Matter movement, a call to action for couple and family therapists. And one of your research interests is couple therapy with African-American couples. Can you talk a little bit about that and why it's important for therapists to take these factors into account when working with couples from different backgrounds? For African-American couples, there's a lot of challenges that our relationships are facing. So African-Americans have the lowest marriage rate.
这种当你结婚并有孩子时，有一种不同程度的承诺来解决这些不同的挑战，以及我们如何解决这个问题。当你没有结婚时，有时这可能会更具挑战性。我们从文献中知道，同居然后结婚的伴侣，这些关系往往稍微不稳定一些。所以我认为同居关系与结婚确实有所不同。话虽如此，再次强调，相似之处多于差异，对吧？沟通问题就是沟通问题。如果你进来，你没有良好的沟通，你不知道如何解决冲突，你的婚姻状况并不重要。
They have the highest divorce rate. So if you think about it, we are really struggling with a lot of our relationships. And 70% of children are born out of wedlock for African-American children. And so when you start to just sit back and think about those statistics and dynamics alone, it's a really powerful problem and opportunity, I would say, to be able to see if we can strengthen those relationships. And so these factors that we're talking about for African-American couples become really critically important for being able to have the healthy relationship.
你需要能够获得技能和工具来建立有效的沟通，并学习如何解决冲突。所以显然有一些基本的事情是通用的，但特别是当你开始考虑，你知道，承诺以及我们对未来有什么，我们对这段关系的奉献程度如何时？婚姻状况确实提供了一些与那些没有结婚的人相比的差异。那么关系中孩子的存在呢？如果存在的话，它如何改变伴侣治疗？嗯，这是一个有趣的问题。这里不是“一刀切”的。所以有一个群体，我之前提到过，
If you came from a background where you did not see a healthy relationship, you can get this intergenerational pattern, right? We know that children who grow up in single parent households are 50% more likely themselves to be divorced and not have that kind of relationship. And so you get this sort of pattern that happens intergenerationalally. And so there's such an opportunity to be able to provide the kind of information about how to have a healthy relationship. What goes into a healthy relationship? What are the things that we need to do? Because a lot of sometimes people just don't know. It's almost analogous to, you know, if you're going to start a business, you're going to probably do some research to be able to figure out how to make
向父母身份过渡是伴侣将经历的最困难的过渡。有所谓的离婚的“双峰分布”，这基本上意味着离婚最有可能发生的两个时期。最常见的是向父母身份过渡。第二常见的是实际上是“空巢”过渡，当那些仅仅为了孩子而在一起的伴侣，孩子去上大学或离家后，伴侣实际上在那段时间离婚。所以孩子可以，这就是为什么我说它不是线性的，因为你有一个风险因素，特别是在前七年左右。
sure this business is going to be successful. And we need to do a very similar thing for our relationships. Because sometimes because of our own sort of traumas or things that have happened in the past or what we didn't see, sometimes things that might seem intuitive or actually counterintuitive and actually you need to do things differently for success in a relationship than you might sometimes otherwise think. And so for couples like African-American couples where you don't have that kind of history and background for how to have a healthy relationship, becomes really important to be able to come in and to get the help because it can get better. Is couple therapy different for people who are legally married versus those who are just living
婚姻中，这与向父母身份过渡重叠，当人们和伴侣经常在育儿时，这很难。对于一些人来说，他们没能度过那个阶段。然后有另一组人可能因为孩子而度过了那个阶段，他们仅仅为了孩子而在一起。所以它实际上有助于保持家庭系统在一起。但后来可能会有那个风险因素。如果他们根本没有做任何事情来培养他们的关系，而他们只专注于
together, even for many years, and do couple therapists treat same-sex and opposite-sex couples any differently? There are a lot more similarities than there are differences, but the differences are what we have to pay attention to. So couples' therapists absolutely will see same-sex couples, non-binary couples, and so absolutely is a part of the work that couples therapists do. I would say, just like I was mentioning before, the importance of finding. a good couples therapist. It also can be helpful to find someone who also is familiar with the
共同育儿的部分，那很难。我在教学或甚至直接与伴侣工作时经常会说的一件事是，共同育儿关系是建立健康关系的必要但不充分条件，意思是如果你在共同育儿上存在分歧，几乎不可能建立健康的关系，因为它在关系中占据了太多的空间和氧气。但你们可以是好的共同育儿者，你们共同育儿做得很好，但你们没有做任何其他事情来培养亲密感或情感联系。当孩子离开，你们不再以同样的方式共同育儿时，这就成了一个风险因素。你们可能没有你们正在寻找或需要的关系连接。所以我们刚才谈到沟通是良好关系的基础，也是人们来找你的主要驱动力之一。我相信是约翰·戈特曼博士提出了“末日四骑士”的概念。
nuances of same-sex couples because there are some important differences and things that need to be paid attention to. But that absolutely is something that couples therapists do work with and do treat. And are there differences between people who are legally married and those who are just living together? Do you treat them the same way? Do they have the same problems or are their problems different? So they are mostly similar in terms of having a long-term relationship, but there is something different between, you know, when you're cohabitating and you're not married, the big difference is that it's just sometimes you don't have the same kind of protections of thinking about sort of, you know, why should we, around commitment, of what things I'm trying to put out there,
同性伴侣的细微差别，因为确实存在一些重要的差异和需要注意的事项。但这绝对是伴侣治疗师会处理和治疗的问题。那么，合法结婚的人和仅仅同居的人之间有什么区别吗？你们对待他们的方式一样吗？他们面临的问题相同吗，还是有所不同？总的来说，他们在维持长期关系方面大多是相似的，但同居和未婚之间确实存在一些不同。最大的区别在于，有时你没有同样的保障，或者在考虑关于承诺的问题时，你可能会想，我们为什么要这样做，我想表达的是，
that this idea of when you're married and you're with children, there's a different level of commitment to be able to work through some of these different challenges and how do we sort of work through this. When you're not married, sometimes that can be sometimes a little bit more challenging. We know from the literature that couples who cohabitate and then get married, those relationships tend to be a little bit more unstable. And so I think there is something different about the cohabitating relationship from being married. That being said, again, there's more similarities than not, right? Communication problem is a communication problem. If you're coming in and you're not having good, you don't know how to be able to resolve conflict, it doesn't matter what your marital status is.
这种观念是，当你结婚并有了孩子时，为了解决这些不同的挑战，你们会有不同程度的承诺，我们该如何共同克服这些困难。当你未婚时，有时这可能会更具挑战性。我们从文献中得知，先同居后结婚的伴侣，其关系往往会稍微不稳定一些。所以我认为同居关系与婚姻关系确实有所不同。话虽如此，正如我所说，它们之间的相似之处多于不同之处，对吧？沟通问题就是沟通问题。如果你来咨询时，你们沟通不畅，不知道如何解决冲突，那么你们的婚姻状况如何并不重要。
You're going to need to be able to get the skills and tools to be able to have effective communication and being able to learn how to resolve conflict. So there are obviously some basic things that are crossed aboard, but particularly when you start to think about, you know, commitment and whether or not what do we have here for the future, what's our level of dedication to this relationship? marital status does provide some differences compared to those who are not. What about the presence of children in a relationship? How does that alter, if it does, couples therapy? Well, it's an interesting. It's not a one side that fits all here. So there is a group where I mentioned earlier,
你们需要掌握能够进行有效沟通的技能和工具，并学会如何解决冲突。因此，显然有一些基本原则是通用的，但当你开始考虑承诺，以及我们对未来有何规划、我们对这段关系的投入程度如何时，婚姻状况确实会带来一些与未婚者不同的影响。那么，孩子在关系中的存在又如何呢？如果存在的话，它会如何改变伴侣治疗？这是一个有趣的问题。这里并没有一刀切的答案。正如我之前提到的，有一类群体，
the transition to parenthood is the most difficult transition that couples will go through. There's what they call this sort of bimodal distribution of divorce, which basically means there are two periods of time when divorce is most likely to happen. The most common is the transition to parenthood. The second most common is actually the transition to empty nest when the couples who stay together just for the sake of the children, children go off to college or leave home, and then the couple actually gets divorced at that period of time. So children can, that's why I mean it's not sort of linear because you have a risk factor, particularly in those first, you know, seven years or so.
向父母角色的转变是伴侣们经历的最困难的转变。有一种所谓的离婚双峰分布，这基本上意味着离婚最有可能发生的两个时期。最常见的是向父母角色的转变。第二常见的是向空巢期的转变，即那些仅仅为了孩子而维持婚姻的伴侣，在孩子上大学或离家后，夫妻双方在那个时期选择了离婚。所以孩子可能会带来影响，这就是为什么我说它不是线性的，因为你面临着风险因素，特别是在最初的七年左右。
of marriage, which overlaps with the transition to parenthood when people and the couples are oftentimes doing childbearing, it's hard. And for some, they don't make it through that. And then there's another group who might make it through because of the kids, and they stay together just for the kids. So it actually helps to sort of keep the, you know, the fan system together. But then there can be that risk factor later. If they have not done anything at all to nurture their relationship and they were only focused
婚姻的前七年，这与向父母角色的转变重叠，当人们和伴侣通常在抚养孩子时，这很艰难。对一些人来说，他们没能熬过那个阶段。还有另一群人可能因为孩子而坚持了下来，他们仅仅为了孩子而维持在一起。所以这实际上有助于维持家庭系统的完整。但之后可能会出现风险因素。如果他们根本没有做任何事情来培养他们的关系，而只是专注于
on the co-parenting piece, that's hard. one of the things that I will oftentimes tell when I'm teaching or when I'm even working with couples directly, the co-parenting relationship is a necessary but not sufficient condition for having a healthy relationship, meaning that it's almost impossible to have a healthy relationship if you're disagreeing about co-parenting because it takes up so much room and oxygen in the relationship. But you could be good co-parents and you co-parent well together, but you haven't done anything else to nurture the intimacy or the emotional connection. And that becomes a risk factor when the children are gone and you're no longer co-parents in that same way. You may not have the kind of relationship connection that you're looking for or needing. So we talked a little while ago about communication being fundamental to a good relationship and one of the major drivers behind people coming to you. I believe it's Dr. John Gottman who came up with the idea of the four horsemen of the apocalypse concept.
共同抚养孩子的部分，那就很困难了。我在教学或直接与伴侣工作时经常说的一件事是，共同抚养关系是拥有健康关系的必要条件，但不是充分条件。这意味着，如果你在共同抚养问题上存在分歧，几乎不可能拥有健康的关系，因为它占据了关系中太多的空间和精力。但你们可能是一对优秀的共同抚养者，合作得很好，却没有做任何其他事情来培养亲密感或情感联系。当孩子们离开，你们不再以同样的方式共同抚养孩子时，这就成了一个风险因素。你们可能没有那种你们正在寻找或需要的关系连接。所以我们刚才谈到沟通是良好关系的基石，也是人们来找你的主要驱动力之一。我相信是约翰·戈特曼博士提出了“末日四骑士”的概念。
There are some things that happen in a relationship that are just, they will doom it. If you have one of these problems and you can't fix it, it's done. Absolutely, absolutely. So I'll say several things to that. So one, as I mentioned before, we were talking about infidelity, not being the number one reason why couples get divorced. The number one reason why couples get divorced is actually money. Money creates a lot of different dynamics. That is actually, and that's true for rich couples and poor couples. It doesn't matter sort of how much money you have is what the money represents,
在一段关系中，有些事情的发生注定会毁掉这段关系。如果你遇到了这些问题却无法解决，那这段关系就结束了。绝对是这样。对此我想说几点。首先，正如我之前提到的，我们谈到不忠并不是夫妻离婚的首要原因。夫妻离婚的首要原因其实是金钱。金钱会产生许多不同的动态。这对于富裕的夫妻和贫穷的夫妻来说都是事实。你拥有多少钱并不重要，重要的是金钱所代表的意义，
which is issues of power, fairness, vulnerability, these sort of psychological factors of what money represents security, anxiety. That's really behind, you know, the psychological variables are really what drives money for being such a difficult issue to work with. So money is a big risk factor for couples if they don't set things up well. Another piece, of course, this gets to John Gottman's four horsemen. You know, how you communicate and how you resolve conflict, it's quite predictive for how the relationship is going to go. If you're doing something what they call stonewalling, for instance, and you're not actually
也就是权力、公平、脆弱性等问题。金钱所代表的这些心理因素，如安全感、焦虑感，才是导致金钱问题难以处理的真正原因。因此，如果夫妻双方没有处理好金钱问题，它就是一个巨大的风险因素。另一个方面，当然，这涉及到了约翰·戈特曼（John Gottman）的“末日四骑士”。你知道，你们沟通的方式以及解决冲突的方式，对于关系的走向具有很强的预测性。例如，如果你在进行所谓的“筑墙”（stonewalling），而你实际上并没有
able to, you go give your partner the silent treatment. That is not a good way to handle conflict. There are very important things for having healthy communication. And when you're not engaged in these sort of healthy things for how do you resolve conflict, that's going to be a real risk factor. And so that is a really important piece here. I love this metaphor that you've used, which is that the relationship is not a tennis match. It's more like playing catch.
能力去沟通，或者你对伴侣采取冷暴力，那不是处理冲突的好方法。健康的沟通有非常重要的原则。当你没有参与这些健康的冲突解决方式时，这就是一个真正的风险因素。所以这一点非常重要。我很喜欢你用的这个比喻，即关系不是网球比赛，而更像是玩抛接球游戏。
Can you explain what you mean when you tell people that? No, yes, great. So, you know, when you're communicating, it's important to slow the communication down. When conflict is happening, oftentimes you're going back and forth and you're trying to hit the ball over the net as hard as you possibly can to try to score a point. You're sort of thinking about, I think I'm right and let me show you how right I am and how wrong you are. And so you're going so fast that you miss the essence of what actually your partner is trying to communicate. So I'm trying to help. couples to say, okay, let's slow down. Tennis back and forth where you are now, you're facing your partner as an opponent, that you're against the fight. That's the wrong way to think about this. But rather, if you're playing catch, it's a much slower game. The whole purpose of playing catch is a toss the ball over gently so your partner can be able to catch it, receive it, you look at the ball, you pick it up, and you toss it back. And that's, you know, I think metaphorically how communication needs to be able to work. You have to be.
你能解释一下你告诉人们这句话的意思吗？好的，没问题。你知道，在沟通时，放慢沟通节奏很重要。当冲突发生时，通常你们会来回争吵，试图尽可能用力地把球打过网，以试图得分。你心里想的是，我认为我是对的，让我向你展示我是多么正确，而你又是多么错误。你们进行得太快，以至于错过了伴侣真正想要表达的核心内容。所以我试图帮助夫妻们说，好吧，让我们慢下来。网球比赛中，你们面对面，把对方当作对手，在进行对抗。这是错误的思考方式。相反，如果是玩抛接球，这是一个节奏慢得多的游戏。玩抛接球的全部目的就是轻轻地把球抛过去，让你的伴侣能够接住、收到，看着球，捡起来，然后再抛回来。我认为，这就是沟通在隐喻层面上应该如何运作的方式。你必须
be able to slow it down. That becomes a really important piece. While we're talking about this, if you don't mind, I would like to just sort of expand on that a little bit because I do think there are some really important communication strategies that couples need to be able to do. And one is when you're in a relationship and you're trying to communicate with your partner, you need to make sure you're speaking for yourself and not mind reading. One of the worst things that you can do is to start telling your partner, hey, this is what you're thinking and this what you're feeling. Doesn't matter how right you are, your partner is not likely going to receive that very well. And so you're going to need to be able to make sure that you're not engaging in
能够放慢节奏。这变得非常重要。在谈论这个话题时，如果你不介意，我想稍微展开讲一下，因为我确实认为夫妻需要掌握一些非常重要的沟通策略。其中之一是，当你在一段关系中试图与伴侣沟通时，你需要确保你是为自己说话，而不是在“读心”。你能做的最糟糕的事情之一就是开始告诉你的伴侣：“嘿，这就是你在想的，这就是你在感受的。”无论你有多正确，你的伴侣都不太可能很好地接受这一点。所以你需要确保你没有进行
mind reading that you're focusing on yourself. And when you're listening to your partner, make sure that you're listening with the goal to understand and not to rebut. Oftentimes, if we're sitting in a relationship and our partner is saying something, we're not really listening for what our partner is really trying to communicate to us. We're trying to evaluate if what our partner is saying is right or wrong. And if we disagree with it, we're then going to build up our rebuttal in our head, and then we just go when we start giving our rebuttal. You have to assume that there is some validity to what your partner is telling you. You have to start with that assumption. Because when you start with the assumption that there is some validity, it will
读心，而是专注于你自己。当你倾听伴侣时，确保你的倾听目标是理解，而不是反驳。通常，如果我们身处一段关系中，伴侣在说些什么，我们并没有真正去听他们试图传达的内容。我们是在评估伴侣说的是对还是错。如果我们不同意，我们就会在脑海中建立反驳意见，然后直接开始反驳。你必须假设伴侣告诉你的内容是有一定合理性的。你必须从这个假设开始。因为当你从“有合理性”这个假设开始时，它会
actually engender curiosity. And curiosity is one of the best things that you can do to have a healthy relationship, to be curious about, oh, wow, you're seeing it this way. That is different than how I was experiencing this or what I was thinking. I want to understand more about what was going on here for you in that way. So you're slowing the conversation down. You're playing catch. You're actually now focused on trying to assume that there's validity. And you want to try to understand what that discrepancy might be between why you were thinking one thing and why your partner was thinking something else. And so being able to do those, I think, are really important. And one last thing, if you allow me to sort of expand on, too, this whole idea of the right, wrong dialectic is really
实际上激发好奇心。好奇心是维持健康关系最好的事情之一，对“哦，哇，你是这样看待这件事的”感到好奇。这与我的经历或想法不同。我想更多地了解你当时的想法。所以你放慢了谈话节奏。你在玩抛接球。你现在实际上专注于假设对方是有道理的。你想尝试理解为什么你认为的一件事与伴侣认为的另一件事之间可能存在的差异。所以我认为能够做到这些非常重要。如果允许我再展开一点，最后一点是，这种关于对错的辩证法确实非常
problematic, meaning that when you begin to, if you're in a relationship and you are focusing on evaluating if your partner is telling you is right or wrong, you're not going to get to a good place. There is a very low correlation between being right and being happy. And so you want to make sure that in a relationship, you are focused on trying to do the things necessary to be able to help engender closeness, to help foster connection rather than being able to be in the sense of opposition and trying to be able to think about, oh, I think I am more right than you. So let me tell you why I'm right and you're not. And so those are some of the real important aspects of communication and conflict resolution that are really important ingredients for the communication to do well.
有问题。意思是，如果你在一段关系中，专注于评估伴侣说的是对还是错，你将无法获得好的结果。正确与幸福之间的相关性非常低。因此，你要确保在一段关系中，你专注于做那些有助于增进亲密感、促进联系的事情，而不是处于对立状态，试图去想：“哦，我认为我比你更正确。所以让我告诉你为什么我是对的，而你是错的。”这些是沟通和冲突解决中一些非常重要的方面，也是沟通顺利进行的重要要素。
Well, last question. I want to go back to something that I mentioned in the introduction is that you teach an undergraduate course that's basically marriage 101. A lot of the stereotypes today about young people is that they want to just date casually and they're not really interested in settling down. Do you find that these undergrads are really interested in learning how to develop strong relationships? What questions do they bring to you in the class? Interestingly, the Marriage 101 course is probably one of the most popular courses that we had at the university. You know, everyone has been very, everyone's interested in relationships. You know, this is true across, this is not a generational thing. I think this is a human thing,
好的，最后一个问题。我想回到我在介绍中提到的事情，你教授一门本科课程，基本上就是“婚姻101”。今天关于年轻人的许多刻板印象是，他们只想随便约会，对安定下来并不真正感兴趣。你是否发现这些本科生真的有兴趣学习如何发展稳固的关系？他们在课堂上会向你提出什么问题？有趣的是，“婚姻101”课程可能是我们在大学里最受欢迎的课程之一。你知道，每个人都非常关心关系。这在各个群体中都是如此，这不是一代人的问题。我认为这是人类共同的问题，
that we are social beings and we are oftentimes driven towards wanting to be in a relationship. And so they are absolutely interested in that. And one of the things that really was behind the impetus for why we developed that course was actually because we realize it's important for people to have a better understanding of who they are in order to be able to select the right kind of partner and to be able to be a healthy partner in order to have a healthy relationship. You know, if we have a lot of self-esteem issues or if we're struggling, with some baggage from our past that we haven't resolved where we're not compassionate with ourselves,
我们是社会性动物，我们往往会被驱动去想要建立一段关系。所以他们绝对对此感兴趣。我们开发这门课程的初衷之一，实际上是因为我们意识到，人们需要更好地了解自己，才能选择合适的伴侣，并成为一个健康的伴侣，从而拥有一段健康的关系。你知道，如果我们有很多自尊问题，或者如果我们正在挣扎，带着过去未解决的包袱，而我们对自己不够宽容，
you know, one of the things that can happen, we're not oftentimes able to receive the kind of love and compassion from someone else and we're not able to give it to ourselves. And so being able to really help students to understand a little bit about their family history, understand the aspects of a relationship, having the right paradigm. Those are all critically important things, and the students really just love it. So they find it very meaningful and are really engaged in the course. And so it's one of the most enjoyable courses that I had to privilege of being a part of. Well, Dr. Chambers, I want to thank you for joining me.
你知道，可能发生的一件事是，我们往往无法接受来自他人的爱和同情，也无法给予自己。因此，能够真正帮助学生了解一点他们的家庭历史，了解关系的各个方面，拥有正确的范式，这些都是至关重要的。学生们真的很喜欢它。他们觉得这非常有意义，并且非常投入到课程中。所以这是我有幸参与的最令人愉快的课程之一。好的，钱伯斯博士，我想感谢你加入我的节目。
I think you have given our listeners a lot of important information, and I hope that it will help them in their relationships. Thank you. Thank you so much for the opportunity to talk about couples in relationships. I really appreciate it. Thank you again. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.spokenof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我认为你为我们的听众提供了许多重要的信息，我希望这能帮助他们改善关系。谢谢。非常感谢你给我这个机会谈论夫妻关系。我真的很感激。再次感谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you like what you heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wienerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·维纳曼（Lee Wienerman）制作。我们的音效编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condiion）。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。